over here next yes hello George I was
wondering if you had any reservations
about making your books into a TV series
if I had any reservations you know it's
it's there's always a certain
trepidation when you when you're gonna
sign the deal you know is this gonna
turn out well or are they gonna you know
are they gonna ruin it
you know I liken it to a mother sending
her children off to you know daycare for
the first time I mean you had this kid
and he's your kid and you spent all the
time with him and you've been in charge
and now you're entrusting them to
strangers and all the strangers gonna
take good care of them is he gonna get
his milk and cookies in time or they
actually a bunch of child molesters who
are just lurking there and they're gonna
get the kid off and you're gonna be gone
and who the hell knows what they're
gonna do but you know I mean I'd met the
people involved you know I loved HBO
shows I loved what they did with Rome
and Deadwood so they had a they had a
terrific track record and David and Dan
I had several meetings with we we
discussed what they wanted to do and
they said all the right things I and and
I'd read their their own work
they were both established writers
themselves and David Benioff in
particular had done some amazing work
with 25th hour and Troy and his his
novels city of thieves and 25th hour was
actually a novel before was at the movie
Kite Runner you know heat so they've
done terrific work so I didn't I didn't
think they were child molesters it
seemed pretty good and you know you have
to you have to take a chance sometime
wonder what is it that Mariel Hemingway
says to Woody Allen in in Manhattan
there's sometimes you got to trust
someone
so I did that too and also the large
dump truck of money did they pull up in
front of your house
sometimes sways you and and you know the
other thing to keep in mind is that the
the books continue to exist by
themselves that Roger Roger Zelazny who
was a good friend of mine had the
misfortune of having his novel damnation
alley made into something that purports
to be a film and it was terrible as a
piece of [ __ ] but they completely ruined
the book but Roger built a whole new
wing on his house with the money that
they paid him for damnation alley and
when he was asked about it he would
always quote James M Cain the famous
noir writer who when when asked famously
well mr. Cain what do you what do you
think about how what Hollywood has done
to your books he would just point to the
wall and say do i Hollywood hasn't done
anything to my books they're they're
right over there they're on the shelves
they're exactly the way I wrote them not
a word has been changed so you know go
go forth and enjoy them and indeed the
original books sell more copies one
thing I've been adamant though from the
from the very start of of my association
with Hollywood and and for every project
I've ever done in Hollywood is to retain
full and complete publication rights in
any deal and to forbid any novelization
so if any if any movie is ever made of
my work we will re release my original
novel and it will sell we will not have
a novelization you know even if they
completely trashed a novel and changed
everything about it people have to go to
the original book and the original book
will benefit from from any sales
generated by the movie or the television
show we won't have some cheesy
novelization written by a hack
which they like to do too but that's one
point where I draw my own personal line
that's a always a deal-breaker for me if
they insist on novelization rights so so
yeah there's always trepidation but it's
it's worked out well in this case and
that's fine you have to know who you're
who you're doing business with when
you're when you are dealing with
Hollywood you know if if Steven
Spielberg comes to you or guillermo del
toro comes to you when they want to
option your work that's one thing if
Jerry Bruckheimer comes to you you know
you got a different situation there and
yet you got to know why you're what
you're looking at going in